I'm about to give Captain Holt his gift
oh did he lift his no gift policy no he
didn't but I figured out a way to buy
him something and trick him into
accepting it you are bad I
oh wait you're making fun of me well I
don't care he would never open a gift
right but what if his gift didn't look
like a gift he would open it exactly I
left it in a cardboard box on his desk
there's no card just the words open now
which I wrote with my wrong hand so he
wouldn't recognize my handwriting
so just to recap you left an unmarked
package on a police Captain's desk on a
random Monday with a suspicious message
written on it looked like it was crawled
by a crazy person mom there's a bomb
everyone else
let's go
gentlemen prepare to start clapping
because I just made a major drug bust
talking about four kilos of cocaine 200
000 cash and
my new partner a tarantula I call him
Jake Jr AKA Spidey Gloom AKA Mrs doubt
spider AKA Joe spyden AKA tarantula
Bassett AKA spydermott Mulroney AKA
tarantulina Jolie what no Charles have
you seen the spider that's a terrible
name sorry why do you have that thing
because they were going to throw them
away but I couldn't let them do that to
my furry little dog it's actually really
scary up close it's horrifying from
everywhere Terry hates Creepy Crawlers
seriously I'm not going to your
apartment if that thing is there all
right fine then he'll just live here and
help me solve crimes get used to him
everyone because me and this spider are
Partners For Life he's gone I left the
cage unlocked and he's gone oh somebody
find him
I'm good I'm out of here he couldn't
have gone far unless he can fly can
tarantulas fly Jake you better find that
spot and I'm not coming back here until
you do
search I think I found it
why are you looking at me like that
it's on my head
guys I have a great idea for a prank
before Holt comes in I'm gonna put ink
on the podium where he puts his hands I
don't think he'll fall for that I did
how I haven't even opened this yet I
guess it's unrelated Captain hold hates
pranks this is gonna backfire man fine
I'll tone it down I'll move his Podium a
foot to the left what he'll be so angry
okay five inches five three three one
one all right I'll move it a half inch
fine it's your funeral oh my God
worst prank ever so stupid halt's not
even gonna notice good morning
you guys it the podium is
you're crazy how did you pull this off
hey
you guys see the dude I brought in today
the drug dealer 81 years old I think
it's the oldest collar of my entire
career I once arrested a 96 year old for
flashing I was terrified he'd die in my
backseat or Flash me my oldest collar
was 78 but the PCP made her fight like
she was 20. what about two 50 year old
twins does that count as 100 year old no
good no you talking all this bags
68. that's not that old yeah but I was
only 20 20. were you even a cop then no
man it was before I got into the academy
Charles isn't talking about his oldest
arrest
oh no yes yes I am yeah oldest arrest 68
like I said God you had sex with a 68
year old when you were in your 20s you
know how it is when you have a chance to
bed an older woman you know that's not
an older woman that's an old woman
that's someone's grandma she was
actually that's how I met her
then don't knock it to your trick she
had a replacement hit with some serious
torque it's like having sex with a
Transformer that is no one's fantasy
I've been going at it for six hours he
won't say a word the guy's a brick wall
not to worry Sarge I'll take it from
here hope you boys brought popcorn
because I'm about to put on a show
well well well I hear you don't like
answering questions Marcus that's fine
by me because I'm not asking him
laughs
nope yeah so looks like we're locked in
for you because you're trapped in here
with a psycho has anyone tried it from
the outside Lock's broken got a call
facilities copy that no rush as I said I
got all the time in the worst little
warming area do you feel any air coming
out of that vent I got nothing we got an
ETA on facilities at least 45 minutes
and I've checked all this paint for lead
right and the room for asbestos I feel
like I'm sucking on a tailpipe in here
Marco everybody get away from the mirror
foreign
I can't breathe hey calm down man I'll
confess just stop freaking out what I
did it I robbed them boom and that's how
it's done I was faking the whole thing
to break him I could have stayed in here
forever good because facilities gonna be
a couple hours we're gonna die in here
[Music]
interesting
very very and sting guys Captain Holt
has no pants on
um
what he has no pants on is what here are
the facts at 11 55 a.m Captain Holton
walked past us holding a hot bowl of
soup at 1203 PM I heard him yell
ouch then at 1207 he called Gina into
his office she entered holding nothing
one minute later she left holding an
opaque bag
Captain Holt's pants were in that bag
his knees are in the breeze he's in his
undies that
oh so you guys want visual confirmation
not really
yeah hey Captain I just need you to sign
something at my desk real quick just
leave it on the couch dismissed okay sir
you're gonna freak yo-yo my eyes in the
precinct and he's giving out autographs
Yo-Yo Ma is on tour in Australia right
now how would you know that
I'm
gonna die
got to take no no no
I called it I blow it
hey and there's another bowl of soup
since you spilled yours earlier but
you're gonna have to come over here to
get it all right barotoxically wasting
time so yes I spilled some minestrone on
my pants and I'm sitting in my underwear
happy yes
sir I need you to sign off on look at us
just three people with pants on having a
normal conversation yep no story here
five four three two and step and step
and knees around the world great form
Captain your calves are looking toy
Peralta what are you doing at Razzmatazz
we need to talk somewhere outside the
precinct yes you're here too great yeah
sir we've discovered the lieutenant
Hawkins is dirty her Squad isn't
investigating the golden gangbang
robbers they are the robbers knees up in
the back sorry Brenda if Hawkins is
robbing banks why she invite you onto a
task force and squat and hold and work
those quads we're working on a case that
could have exposed her this way she can
keep tabs almost turn it
normally I'd say we'd report this to
internal affairs world back but Hawkins
is one of the most revered detectives in
the NYPD and who
want to go after her you know proof to
back it up well then I guess that only
leaves us one option and
that sales find out everything we can
about the squad and take her down from
the inside keep wagging back there I am
wagging Brenda listen up everyone we had
a murder this morning the Vic was found
at 8 45 by a dog walker who let herself
into his apartment oh my God it's
Franzia this is the work of Johnny
Franzia my white whale he's finally
resurfaced not this again yes this again
Johnny Franzia has been on a murder
spree for the past 10 years and every
time he kills someone he taunts me look
there's a deck of cards you say that
whenever there's cars at a crime scene
you know how many people own cars Jake
then explain this Johnny franzia's
catchphrase is Deuces or wild now look
around the apartment two chairs two
paintings two pillows there are three
lamps you think Franzia gives a damn
about lamps you sound so dumb right now
this is why you don't have an arch
nemesis Terry because you focus on the
wrong details maybe I don't have an arch
nemesis because I saw all my crimes
that's a productive thing to say to me
morning everyone good morning sir Hey
look
food stained beds who are you wearing
porridge
um
oatmeal
oh my
not only giving up on life it's
loneliness ever since Kevin left for a
sabbatical in Paris he hasn't been the
same I tried to get him out
I did him to bar trivia but he turned
trivia Newton John needed the help we're
nationally ranked it's no big deal
you're right it's not well aren't you
all just a bunch of big-hearted dum-dums
you want to make him feel less lonely
oh this is how you do it a case File
yeah dude loves work I thought all your
cases were closed you were bragging
about it so much last night I couldn't
hear the end of the neighbor's fight
depended in sex it always does it didn't
make me horny it's a cold case for my
first year as a detective is it active
again no but hold don't have to know
that so you're gonna lie to him no I'm
going to make him forget about his
sadness through the power of
welcome to the most anticipated event in
this Precinct history the auction for
ah the suitcase of mystery exactly Jacob
this puppy's been in the lost and found
since
1976. no one alive today knows its
contents I'm happy to say captain Holt
has finally given me permission to
auction it off I'll let you give me a
spray tan any shade you want Jake
willing to sacrifice his dignity who can
top it massage I'll give you a massage
Charles going in the wrong direction and
getting himself disqualified interesting
approach orange Jake going once going
twice I'll show you a picture of me in
high school there's side pony oh Rosa
coming in hot Rosa coming in hot I'll
also give you full control of my hair
and wardrobe I'll go on a date with you
sold to Jake not to school that really
freaked me out and I just want this to
end now
oh
so there's this suitcase I don't care
yeah